also millions around the world getting
off to this story of abuse blatant
emotional and physical abuse most of it
in a cultish sexual setting starting
with a flashback as you can see we have
company this episode
[Music]
30 seconds of intro for a webseries
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show whose host aka me went to see
Fifty Shades of Grey purely for research
purposes I swear I know you don't
believe me but why else would I wilfully
volunteer to enter a lion's den of
hundreds of thirsty women all looking to
enjoy the r-rated exploits of a 27 year
old billionaire playboy with a BDSM urge
trust me I have better things to do with
my time Thomas of show them one example
of things I can do with my time yeah
sure thanks but as I sat there awkwardly
slumping down in my chair to avoid
anyone recognizing me one of the things
I was dumbfounded by was that the
audience saw this movie as romantic
romantic maybe they were blinded by the
fast cars million-dollar penthouses
chiseled abs perfect chin tousled hair
cute little twinkle in his eyes oh hey
I'm sorry I don't know what happened to
be there but what I do know is that
Christian Grey in all his brooding
damaged hunkiness implements a clear
pattern of behavior that goes way beyond
bad influence throughout the movie
Christian Grey engages in what's known
as thought reform otherwise called
indoctrination as he seduces the young
Anastasia Steele throughout the movie
and when I say indoctrination I mean
that grey follows the exact steps that
real-life cults use to brainwash
innocent people the same steps cults use
to get people to drink poisonous
kool-aid or worship this guy who said
that aliens gave him a pair of sex
robots seriously except grey wants to
you know spank anesthesia really hard
that's it really she asks to see how bad
it gets and he just spanks her with a
belt kinda expecting more from a guy who
with ropes chains and whips everywhere
don't believe me well let me show you
just how fifty shades are fade up this
gets I still can't believe that that is
the signature line from the movie in
books of Fifty Shades a roll credits
stealing another channels cliche cliche
as I just mentioned thought reform is a
kind of indoctrination defined as a
series of manipulative techniques used
to get people to do something they
wouldn't otherwise do and when you
consider that the entire plot of the
movie is one guy getting one girl a girl
who has never had sex mind you to sign a
kinky sex contract dictating all the
things he's gonna do to dominate her
yeah
there's a little bit of that going on
but before we get into the specific
cult-like steps that gray follows let's
take a second to meet our victim 21 year
old Anastasia Steele she's an immensely
shy college senior a loner organized who
only owns one skirt and still uses a
flip phone in 2015 she lacks
self-confidence I don't think I'd fit in
here look at me is unassertive and
honestly outside of that there's really
not much to know about me and with her
about to graduate she's entering a very
vulnerable part of her life with no
clear direction on what to do next she
is in short the perfect subject for
thought reform though Colts will target
anyone researchers generally agree that
those who are most susceptible are
individuals who are ignorant unassertive
gullible and lack self-confidence all
traits that we see throughout
Anastasia's first scenes with gray and
I'm not the only one to notice Christian
knows her type very well you said you're
an English major tell me was it
Charlotte brontë Jane Austen or Thomas
Hardy who first made you fall in love
with literature and this is a man who
explicitly states earlier that very
scene that he knows how to manipulate
people I've always been good at people
or motivates them what incentivizes them
what inspires them so immediately we're
presented with a young poor unconfident
girl looking for answers being courted
by an older confident billionaire the
power dynamic for indoctrination is
certainly there which means we should
look at the progression cults use as
they indoctrinate new members for that
we can follow a convenient eight step
process yes there's actually a standard
psychological step by step guide for
building your very own cult it's kind of
like building an IKEA coffee table but
easier because there's none of those
funny little L wrenches host of really
smart webseries pretends not to know
these wrenches which I know are cold
Allen wrenches thank you very much
nevermind anyway the general philosophy
about cult indoctrination is built on
getting your target in this case
Anastasia to get into the habit of
saying yes first a small harmless things
which gradually over time become bigger
more extreme sex slave ething it's the
classic story of frogs being placed into
hot water if you turn up the temperature
slowly enough the frogs never leave the
pot until they boil to death so how does
Anastasia boil
let's see step one the cult recruiter
gets the target to say yes to a
non-threatening event it can be anything
from a workshop to a poetry reading to a
party for Anastasia there are a couple
early yeses she takes Christians offer
of the pencil in the interview she takes
the business card at the hardware store
but the first big yes comes when Ana
agrees to have coffee with Christian for
the first time it's the first time
they're meeting independent of other
reasons just to spend time together but
it's just coffee that's normal you're
thinking telling the audience what
they're thinking cliche and yes you're
right it is just coffee if a cold were
to just come out and say hey you there
cut off all your ties with your loved
ones and jump aboard our space love
comet then you'd probably run away
immediately
same thing with grey it's a slow burn he
can't just be like butt plugs activates
and expect that to work I mean you gotta
at least buy me a drink first and that's
exactly what he does but it's at this
coffee when the next phase of Anna's
indoctrination begins the love bomb no
we're not talking about a hippies
nuclear strategy this is when the cult
showers attention praise even gifts on
to the target basically they're trying
to create a positive association in the
targets brain between the cult and
feeling good that way when the
opportunity to spend time together comes
up again the target will be more likely
to say yes in Fifty Shades starting with
that coffee grey turns his charm beam
fully on to Anna asking about her family
giving her food and the next day what
does Anna find on her doorstep a big
steaming pile of lumber in the form of
signed first edition books by her
favorite author a gift that Anna
recognises must have cost a fortune
she's being showered with presents as
grey works to associate positive
feelings with her thinking of him and
that's before he really cranks up the
pressure with new clothes computers and
even cars Christian gray be dropping
love bombs all over this place and with
it comes Phase three of his plan
dangling the prize right in front of her
four Colts that prize tends to vary from
happiness to a sense of community and
purpose to well third even the answers
to the world's mysteries it's the value
for joining the cult so what prize is
gray dangling in front of Anna his mini
gray you get what I mean
cringe-worthy penis joke it's him at
least to begin with it's the promise of
being loved by a sexy rich powerful man
Anna admits to being a romantic so to
find her mr. Darcy the billionaire
brooder with a cold exterior and loving
interior is her dream and gray knows it
twice he almost kisses her but then
doesn't the first time happens as they
leave the coffee shop after a
particularly romantic moment where he
saves her from getting hit in the street
the second comes after he quote-unquote
rescues her after a night of clubbing
and drinking scene we'll talk about more
later in both instances notice that he
lingers even after he says things like I
should let you go he tempts her but
ultimately refuses the kiss that she
clearly wants this is an important step
in Anna's indoctrination as he's
dangling the prize just out of her reach
until she gets to step 4 soon after his
second denial he becomes more explicit
saying
Anastasia finally responds with then and
only then does he bring up the contract
until I have your written consent it's
funny to us as the audience because it
seems like such an odd thing to say but
for grey this moment is entirely
calculated step 4 of the indoctrination
process is getting an agreement from the
target that they want the prize don't
you want to be financially independent
you know you want the secret of life
don't you
you crave signing a contract stating
that you'll be my submissive sexual
object rights sign me up
gray
has led her on taunting her with the
prospect of kisses and sex but it's not
until she verbally confirms that yes yes
she wants that that he drops the bomb
about what his end goal is
she's enough on the hook at this point
that he knows he's not gonna lose her
with a weird comment like that but then
look what he does not until I have your
written consent when later he avoids it
he's planted the seed but he knows
there's still a longer game to play but
Ana doesn't walk away doesn't ask
further questions and he rewards her
good behavior with the long-awaited kiss
a passionate moment in the elevator he
appears like he can't control his urges
anymore but remember this is a man who
explicitly states that he has control
over every part of his life this kiss
isn't a moment of passion it's a
calculated moment of conditioning so Ana
finally has her prize or at least the
taste of it and obviously she's being
led on to one more then grey ups the
ante with his next date a helicopter
ride to his private top floor penthouse
and in the process he willfully changes
the game the prize he's dangling isn't
just a pretty set of eyes and chiseled
abs anymore it's a driver private
flights million-dollar apartments the
prize has gotten bigger and Anna's
almost got the winning ticket except for
Gray's non-disclosure agreement on the
table he doesn't pull this thing out
until he's laid out all the benefits of
being with him and watched this she
signs it immediately with zero
hesitation I mean she signs it so
quickly I doubt she even read the thing
and after she puts her John Hancock on
the line what's her first question after
reading it I mean just like the frogs
the heats turned up and she's not even
flinching she signs the contract with
the explicit expectation of reward but
grey is still dangling and once again
refuses her the intimacy that she's
looking for because just having sex with
Ana isn't his ultimate goal and that
leads to the introduction of the
infamous playroom The Velvet gymnasium
and clearly she's freaked out I mean who
wouldn't be really she just wants her
roll in the hay and he's pulling out the
handcuffs and the legalese
it's not ready enter step 5 shutting
down your dissent by threatening to
withhold the prize this is where the
cult starts to get serious the cell
becomes a bit more aggressive the target
is encouraged to do things they might
not want to do devote more time to the
group recruit on their behalf
hey do's adopt more extreme beliefs but
when the target expresses resistance to
these greater demands the cult shuts
down their arguments by withholding that
all-important prize and in Fifty Shades
- Christian Grey its butt plugs or
nothing Fifty Shades and my Saturday
nights
oh sure Ana you can have this apartment
but you'll have to live here between
Friday and Sunday and you'll have to be
grazed subservient and kneel Forum oh
and by the way he still won't sleep with
you even after you're done in the
x-rated romper room and when Ana
hesitates completely understandably I
might add grey is like no okay then
peace out Dawg this is how I do
seriously
she asks anything nope sorry grey has
shut down her descent by threatening to
withhold everything no penthouse no
helicopter none of that hickory-smoked
grey sausage not unless you sign that
contract
welcome to the cult oh and then he finds
out that she's still a virgin virgin and
just to sweeten the pot has sex with her
the powerplay all on its own just so she
can see what she'll be missing and
without getting too graphic noticed that
he pleasures her something he's made it
very clear he's not interested in at all
as evidenced by this quote it's just a
tactic he's using to sweeten the pot to
make signing the contract a little
extra-special then it's on to step 6 the
establishment of guilt the target is in
the door so now what do you do to
reprogram their thoughts by shaming them
making them feel guilty for not
appreciating the cult its leaders or its
beliefs enough called indoctrination
techniques are starting to sound like my
mother's parenting skills what this does
is break down the recruits perception
and replaces it with one approved of by
the cult leadership in Gray's case he
makes Anastasia feel guilty by saying
things like I've never
anyone in the helicopter I've never had
sex my own bed she's the only one to
have received this treatment it should
feel special about this gift he's given
her he also tells his personal sob story
that he's broke him that he's 50 shades
of effed-up making her feel guilty for
questioning his tastes he's just a poor
wilting flower and the strain shows we
repeatedly see Anna crying on the phone
going to bed conflicted about how she
should be feeling is she wrong to be
cautious of this man pushing her into a
realm that she's not comfortable of
course not
look those are the questions gray wants
her to be asking it shows cracks in her
resistance that isn't love
that's the effects of calculated
psychological torment step 7
the carrot and the stick let me cite
this word for word from one resource on
the subject behavior is reinforced by
rewarding good behavior and punishing
bad behavior that's a direct quote now
let's look at a quote from Christian
after he reveals his playroom to
Anastasia I have rules if you follow
them I'll reward you if you don't I'll
punish you
that too is a direct quote need i say
more obvious rhetorical question is
obvious actually yes
in psychology this is called operant
conditioning basically it's using
rewards and punishments to incentivize
one type of behavior over another
rewarding your dog with a treat because
it rolled over operant conditioning
giving your sex slave a new laptop
because she survived a flogging operant
conditioning expecting a soon every time
you hear this ding operant conditioning
which leads to step 8 the final phase
controlling the recruits identity
information and environments all these
other steps are how the person gets
sucked in but this is how the cult keeps
them in isolating them from friends and
family
changing the recruits name randomly
alternating between praise and love and
scorn and Punishment removing the
recruits ability to choose by
controlling things like money food and
career and notice that grey has been
doing all of these things the entire
time from the first moments of the movie
a nasty
repeatedly corrects Christian saying to
call her Anna instead of Anastasia he
willfully ignores this continuing to
call her by your full name at the coffee
shop he gives her the muffin and tells
her to eat and again a few scenes later
there are they eat this and drink this
card when it comes to alternating
between praise and punishment he appears
interested in Anna and the coffee shop
but then rushes out to keep her off
balance punishing her for no fault of
her own by buying her new clothes
computers and cars
Anastasia's financial independence is
virtually gone grey is even so generous
as to get rid of her old car for her and
at the bar like the fifth scene in the
movie he physically removes Anastasia
from the party blocking out longtime
friend Jose and having his brother run
interference on her best friend Kate
taking Anastasia to a place he deems
appropriate when let's face it there was
zero reason for him to insert himself
into that situation in the first place
let alone bring her anywhere other than
her own apartment
he's already isolating her in the first
30 minutes of the movie shaping her
identity and managing her resources like
the good cult leader that he is but then
things take on a whole new meaning once
she's inside the happy little love nest
cult members are told what to eat what
to wear when to sleep and look where
Anastasia is her schedule is dictated by
his demands when he tells her to she
must do her hair in a ponytail and wait
for him kneeling by the door hands just
so the contract requires that she only
eat foods from a certain list and when
she seeks an escape needs to clear her
head with the help of her family back in
Georgia because you know some of this
she might need to talk to someone about
who's there to interrupt I bet you can
guess Christian Grey how romantic but
hey that's just a theory of film theory
and post doesn't give special guests
signature closing line well then go for
it okay then that's just a theory a film
Theory thanks for watching special guest
ruins closing line by saying it too
quickly
ding hey you just arrived a 16 minute
long video about 50 shades of grey so I
must be doing something right here might
as well subscribe speaking of your
life's too
eighteen minutes ago remember that
cold-open if you want to see me collab
with cinemasins to nitpick this movie to
death click right here trust me it is
cathartic you were still watching this
video meaning you haven't clicked over
sin on you viewer or if you're not
interested in either of those options
let me know by clicking do you think
Anastasia and Christians relationship is
abusive or not did I convince you or are
you still head over heels let me know by
clicking an option now if you'll excuse
me I need to go say oh my because
seriously I forgot to include a joke
about that and script and need to tag it
in somewhere and it only seemed to fit
here